when she's not Hawking cell phones she's
been known to turn into some
Unforgettable furry creatures and pop up
in hilarious comedies here's the story
of Lily Adams AKA Milana Weintraub
Milana vintrub's first Big Break came in
1995 at the age of eight when she
appeared on three episodes of the
classic medical drama ER that led to a
gig on the popular daytime soap opera
Days of Our Lives on which she played a
young version of Kristen Blake who had
later become Kristen DiMera the
character of Kristen is one of the
show's main villains as Vine Trev
recalled to Esquire in 2015 it was
really weird I actually don't have tons
of memories from it I played someone in
a flashback version I ended up not
auditioning for that they just called me
after they saw me on ER to do that as is
fairly typical of long-running soap
operas the role of Kristen has been
played by many different actors over the
years considering that maybe there's a
chance that vine Trump could one day
reprise the role as an adult someday
soon after Days of Our Lives find drug
booked a small but notable role on an
episode of the Disney Channel sitcom
Lizzie McGuire entitled Gordo's video
the season one episode concerns Lizzie's
friend Gordo setting up hidden cameras
around the school in the midst of doing
so he happens to catch Vine treb's
character eating in belching
appropriately enough her character was
officially billed as cute burper as she
recalled to Esquire I didn't even really
have to burp but I practiced my burps
for a long time before that I'm a
professional disgusting person fine
Trump made two more appearances on
Lizzie McGuire on the episode Here Comes
Aaron Carter she plays a dancer and she
later appears as an extra in season
two's you're a good man Lizzie McGuire
as she noted to Esquire comedy came
early I knew when I was a kid that I was
silly and I knew that I liked people who
were funny but I don't think I knew I
was funny I didn't really think about it
well you've got to figure out a way to
get everyone to see this
with ER Days of Our Lives and Lizzie
McGuire on her resume then Trump had a
pretty good run as a child actor but
then she nearly quit the industry for
good her reason wasn't burnout or
exposure to Vices or anything dramatic
like that instead she simply thought
that it wasn't for her as she explained
to Esquire I stopped around Middle
School in high school I remember
thinking I should probably focus on
something more realistic this is
probably not going to work out I have
High Hopes but that's probably not
enough to make it in film but vintrub
couldn't quite shake the acting bug when
she went to college that's a terrible
bout of boredom during that time in her
life convinced her to return she
attended the University of California
San Diego but she didn't particularly
enjoy it until she got herself on stage
as she divulged to Esquire they had a
really great theater program so I just
took theater classes so I could not go
crazy and keep myself busy I totally got
sucked back in when van drubb won the
role of Lily Adams in the ATT
commercials she thought it would be just
another short-term acting gig but the
response was so strong that within three
years she had appeared in more than 40
ads for the Telecom company as ATT vice
president of advertising Valerie Vargas
revealed to ad week in 2016. the first
spot was so successful for us that we
thought let's do another one and then
another one and then another one it was
so well received that we kept bringing
her back so what is the secret behind
the success of these commercials
according to Hank Pearlman of hungry man
the company that produces them I think
milana's Lily resonates with audiences
because she's a multi-dimensional
character in a way that's rare for
commercials we try as hard as we can not
only to make her funny but to make her a
strong smart and human as possible who's
on TV now
NBC's time jumping tear-jerking family
drama This Is Us was one of the most
popular broadcast network shows of the
2010s and early 2020s over the course of
its six seasons the Emmy award-winning
series was a ratings Juggernaut that
also served as a Showcase of some
amazing actor This Is Us was beloved for
its unique style of switching back and
forth between three siblings growing up
in the 80s and 90s and their adult lives
in the present day the oldest sibling
was Kevin Pearson played by Justin
Hartley a dissatisfied TV star who
leaves his top-rated show and joins an
Off-Broadway play called back of an egg
find Trump had a recurring role on this
is us as Sloane Sandberg a playwright
who dates Kevin for a brief spell she
ultimately appeared in a total of eight
episodes in the Show's first season fine
job had some serious comedy training
having studied improv at the Upright
Citizens Brigade and started a number of
CollegeHumor videos that humorous
background has led to some small but
memorable roles in several high-profile
projects in the 2016 Ghostbusters reboot
for example she made a brief
dialogue-free appearance as subway rat
woman the scene involves her reacting
with visible disgust when scores of
Ghost Rats poured out of a subway
station the director of that movie was
Paul feek who also worked with vine treb
on the short-lived Yahoo screen sitcom
other space feintrub seems to be a
favorite of another popular comedy
director as she popped up a couple of
times on the Netflix series love which
was co-created by Judd Apatow she played
Natalie the ex-girlfriend of the main
character Gus while she's not yet
nayla's name bonetrub has certainly been
rubbing shoulders with the right people
it's 11 am and you're stoned and you're
at my house I'm worried in the summer of
2017 Melana Weintraub landed one of the
most sought after roles in Hollywood she
was cast as Doreen green AKA Squirrel
Girl on Marvel's new Warriors a
superhero comedy series that was set to
air on freeform the show is going to
revolve around 6 20 somethings dealing
with the challenges of young adulthood
and being a superhero Vine Trump was a
relatively surprising choice for such a
high profile part especially since
better known actors such as Anna
Kendrick and Shannon Purser had publicly
lobbied to play the character but
ultimately Vine Trump's admission into
the club that is the Marvel Cinematic
Universe wound up rather muted in 2019
freeform and Disney canceled several
small screen projects that were not set
to air on Disney plus including new
Warriors but Vine Trump eventually did
get a chance to play Squirrel Girl as
she voiced the character on the animated
short series Marvel Rising initiation
and the TV movie Marvel Rising secret
Warriors she also played her again on
the narrative podcast Marvel Squirrel
Girl the unbeatable Radio Show in
addition to her acting career Milana
vintrub has been known for putting pen
to paper or finger to keyboard as the
case may be she's been credited as a
writer on five Robot Chicken episodes as
well as multiple College Humor sketches
outside of sketch comedy she has a
co-writing credit on the 2019 film
Mother's Little Helpers which she also
starred in she's also written for
websites like The Daily Beast and pop
sugar as well as on her own Instagram
where she offers unique perspectives on
family Judaism and the acting life
beindrubs writing has even been
nominated for awards in 2020 Chu is
recognized as part of the writing team
for the streaming sketch comedy show
Making fun with Aquila and Milana at the
YouTube streamy Awards in her mini
series that moment when was nominated
for a Webby award and three Telly Awards
a squirrel isn't the only furry creature
that vine Trump has inhabited in 2021
she starred as a mail carrier named
Cecily in the horror comedy movie
werewolves within when a blizzard causes
the residents of a small town to seek
shelter in a lodge an even bigger
problem is revealed when a werewolf
starts picking off the characters one by
one as the lack of trust gradually grows
within the group The Bodies continue to
pile up be a good neighbor
like Mr Rogers
with guns though with guns yes skip
ahead if you don't want to be spoiled
but in the end Cecily in the friendly
forest ranger named Finn are still alive
the evidence seems to point to Finn as
the werewolf but that's a big fake out
as it turns out that Cecily was the
lycanthrope all along and she planted
the seeds of paranoia to make it easier
to hunt everyone down maybe she wasn't a
fan of their current cell phone plans
findtrub earns some rave reviews for the
movie David erlich of Indy wire for one
declared Milana Vine trub is radiating
movie star potential in a Winston
performance that Shades her natural
comic sass with all sorts of self-aware
texture or you could be me in the 2022
essay for the Daily Beast Alana
Weintraub wrote about some health
problems that she suffered back in 2020
that seriously impacted her quality of
life as it turned out she hurt one of
her ankles so badly that she couldn't
move her foot the injury sent painful
jolts through her body a sensation she
compared to the complicated and
difficult labor she experienced when
giving birth to her first child that
comparison may have come as a surprise
to many of her fans as she had kept her
motherhood Journey under wraps before
then but as it turned out fine Trump and
her husband had welcomed a baby boy back
in may 2021. he arrived perfectly
healthy but the labor experience wasn't
so simple as the baby's head was pushing
against his mom's spine during the
delivery which resulted in tremendous
pain for her while Weintraub did reveal
some of her motherhood story she's also
kept the rest of it private as she
hasn't disclosed her son's name in
addition to her Showbiz career Vine trip
has made time for advocacy this includes
being outspoken about abortion rights as
she had an abortion herself when she was
25. in her 2022 essay for the Daily
Beast she revealed that at the time she
was still taking random jobs to get by
and thus was not in a good Financial
space to raise a child so when she
accidentally forgot to take her birth
control and got pregnant she immediately
had an abortion at her doctor's office
when vine Trump eventually did have a
baby she was able to Bear difficult
labor because she chose to go through it
she emphasized that both her experiences
with abortion and birth have impressed
upon her the right for all Americans to
have the freedom and power to make their
own choices about their bodies lives and
futures
Milana Weintraub was born in 1987 in
Uzbekistan when it was a part of the
Soviet Union but she spent most of her
life in the United States her father
meanwhile spent much of his time working
at his business in Russia during an
appearance on the podcast meditative
story find Trump shared what it was like
to grow up with a dad who was around
only intermittently while he split his
time evenly during her Elementary School
years his time away from her increased
as she got older this resulted in him
missing a lot of important events in her
life including her about Mitzvah
findtrip's father continues to spend
much of his time away from his daughter
though they do manage to stay in touch
over the film and Via occasional
in-person visits he also flew to the U.S
after the birth of her son although
covid-19 pandemic protocols required him
to quarantine for five days before he
could play with his grandson while Vine
Trump feels that she now has a pretty
good relationship with her dad she wants
to have a different relationship with
her own son that isn't similarly long
distance
foreign